yeah we're gonna talk about the serious
nature of these people have gone so
insane check us out you've probably
already seen it you probably heard a lot
about this George Washington statue is
covered in a burning American flag
before being toppled by up to 40
Portland protestors in Oregon and I
think they got a look at this these
Jenna Seidel colonists yeah there it is
f cops
16:19 spray-painted on the statue that
makes me mad and that's exactly the
point
16:19 is fake news yeah it's that
addiction the desperate attempt to get
more recognition to get retweets to get
comments when ya win prizes man so the
16:19 thing is they're literally trying
to argue that the u.s. is a slave aqua
see that the country was found in its
insides true inception was 1619 when the
first slave came and that is such insane
BS yep because there's so many points at
which you can claim the real country
emerged or whatever what the founding
fathers were for one a product other
time many of them opposed it they I
think many of them didn't do enough they
can they and they compromised for sure
and there's no defense for slavery but
they laid the groundwork for something
important that helped get rid of this
and then there were a bunch of really
famous abolitionists who use that
framework to win and justify their
positions but these the issue here with
George Washington being toppled over is
that I think with this addiction we've I
think was Jordan Peters in a pointed
this out we know when the right goes too
far yeah we don't have a point at which
the left has gone too far and it seems
like they're trying to find that I mean
we're serious man I agree this is insane
you the problem is the left owns the
cultural institutions yep you're right
it's really funny when I when I tell
might like a lot of my regular normal
friends this they're like what are you
talking about Donald Trump's the
president and I'm like what is trim
gotten done Barack Obama created created
daca under executive order okay
and then Trump tried repealing it under
executive order and they said he can't
do it's illegal it's like so Obama can
make it through what that makes sense no
it doesn't so they write their arguments
try to justify it but I'm like listen
man I get the Trump's the president
that's that's legit I mean that gives a
lot of power the Republicans are in the
Senate they're not doing anything but
come on man the if if they can tear down
a statue of George Washington and
where's where's Don Lemon where's Chris
Cuomo why isn't a single Democrat coming
out and saying destroying the the
village of our first president is wrong
right because they don't care yeah
because they're they're they're addicts
and they're like whatever you say it's
like they're they're they're taking
their cues from drug-addled maniacs who
are scratching their faces off yep so
this work it's even crazier look I get
it man look you get a bunch of dumb kids
they're gonna tear down some statues all
right we can we can we can say okay okay
the kids are playing a dumb game they're
addicted they're on social media but it
really does reach that that that crazy
point right here and why City Council
members call for Thomas Jefferson statue
to be removed from City Hall that's not
the kids anymore it's not the kids
anymore man no the drug addicts are now
in our government so let me let me ask
you something based on the conversation
so for those that may be just popping in
to the segment the gist of it was that
people use their phones way too much
creating an addiction and they
constantly have to tweet things to
one-up themselves to satisfy that
addiction so their rhetoric gets more
and more extreme until they're tearing
down statues and screaming for
revolution and it makes no sense this is
this is why nothing they fight for makes
sense it's why they're always eating
each other and contradicting each other
because just an addiction to get
something right but look but not now
that we have the gist of this mental
addiction and how its withering away
their brains and their prefrontal cortex
could you imagine if we created a
government where one party was just
completely meth addled and one party was
just like regular working-class people
no I can't you'd have a bunch of drug
addict people being like I don't know I
think we gotta raise taxes cuz I need
meth you know I'm saying like we should
we should we should knock down the
statues we should melting down selling
exciting meth
you'd be like dude those things won't
help us that's destroying our country
but you have a large portion of people
all scratchin and you know demanding
drugs they wouldn't say that they would
be going and taking the lobbying money
like oh yeah that well I'm fighting for
this I'm fighting for this but because I
just got paid from this person who
it's paying me a lot of money to fight
for what they want and then you have the
let you'd have like Nancy Pelosi and
she'd walk into a room and be like well
you know the young people really like
meth so we're gonna get on our knees and
you know inject it straight up like just
do whatever the young people want well I
guess if they're doing it we should do
it too cool yeah just give them what
they want cuz they're desperately trying
to win yeah and then they start
compromising where Joe Biden's like you
know the thing with runo whoa meth is
that do you know I'll do a little bit
but not too much that's literally what's
happening with Biden only do it on the
weekends they're the compromising with
with you know like for the Democrats to
compromise with what these activists
represent would be straight-up like them
saying okay we'll take a little bit of
your addiction like you're unwell
you're completely ignorant to history
and you're violent yeah you know what
we'll we'll incorporate a little bit of
that into into our party now the
Republicans are just standing there I
don't know what they're doing who knows
yeah they're they're probably addicted
to in the other way round because if you
think about it we weren't ready for
social media right we talked about this
yeah so government is wasn't ready for
social media they're all humans they're
all in in social media now they're
they're seeing these people that are
tweeting at them and they're getting the
addiction also from these crazy people
that are like propping them up like wow
you're our champion except social media
bans the ones who get to addicted the
Conservatives who go too far in their
addiction get banned but not on the Left
not on the Left right so there it is
right so we so what's happening the
Republican Party is they're kind of just
standing around with their thumbs up
their bum like they've always been doing
I've never had any any you know I've
never cared much for the Republican
Party they have not been involved that
group you know in a city those were my
Democrats yeah but the Democrats are
increasingly allowed to embrace this
insanity because the people who run
Twitter or Twitter are the dealers men
it's true they're progressive they're
the dealers and they don't want to ban
their own ideas mm-hmm they don't want
to ban their friends so they've created
this drug addiction this this
technological addiction that's melting
the brains of these people you know
and the drug addicts are screaming ban
the Conservatives so they do yep and
that what that leaves you with it leaves
you with some some you know addicted
conservatives for sure but they're kept
in check yep they can't go too far and
they know it so sometimes a conservative
will overdose someone on the right will
will if the equivalent of social media
oh being they know how much they can get
away with like what's the dosage of
spicy memes you can post before you
finally come for you and you're done
you're digitally dead mmm-hmm so
conservatives don't cross that line
anymore the left has no line they've
literally called for violence
they've there's actually a Twitter
account that was for the George
Washington statue a Twitter account gave
the address and said let's go do it
Facebook there's there's someone sent me
this picture from Facebook of someone
killing a cop with a knife to the throat
I was like why did I just see that now I
didn't see it on to it or on Facebook
myself so I don't know but people are
like how is this allowed what are we
seeing someone yep so you know the we
were talking about yesterday the the
antifa fist right gripping the snake and
we brought it up it was actually a Nazi
thing it's like look it's the same thing
someone posted it on Facebook
banned so the context for that is you
know the Gadsden flag
it's the coiled snake don't tread on me
the far-left took the revolution fist
which is like this it's that it's
actually I believe it's the Spanish
Communists symbol from the Spanish Civil
War okay and now it's been appropriated
by a bunch of other leftist groups they
put the fist strangling the Gadsden
snake somebody brought this up to me
that there's actually that's actually
Nazi iconography there's a there was a
Nazi propaganda of an arm strangling a
snake and so we were making the point
that if they're gonna claim Trump's
triangle is Nazi then why aren't they
right exactly well Facebook banned Trump
and banned the showing that the
comparison of the the Nazis the Nazi
iconography mm-hmm so they get it they
get away with it yeah and then the
Democrats are looking at their
constituents and what do they see
lunatics I think it's I think Trump
should not have won in 2016 no
absolutely not no no I'm not saying like
he didn't deserve to when I'm saying
that by all statistics and the will of
the people he shouldn't have except for
the fact that social media
loonatics on the left to get away with
whatever they want so regular people
were turned off yeah and it gave Trump
the little tiny boost he needed cuz they
were because he did win by a decent
electoral margin but there were many
states where he won by only a few
thousand votes maybe like seven to ten
thousand votes mom you get enough people
who are on social media or are seeing
this stuff and they're just like these
people are insane
that's why I don't believe it today you
know that they're saying that Trump is
gonna lose I can't I can't believe it
maybe it's true I don't believe it that
he's gonna lose yeah we're we're in a
blue state right or blue area we're in
heavy blue like heavy blue heavy blue I
walked around the neighborhood I haven't
seen any Democratic signs
I saw Trump signs so you see they're out
there to support it surrounded by Trump
supporters so it's like the air I don't
know the area we are in isn't just a
blue area okay it is like this district
will never go Republican yeah for sure
will never happen oh my god
yeah I said but Trump would never get
elected but that's why I'm saying this
the severity of you seeing Trump signs
is like in the Philly suburbs and there
are red areas over here mm-hmm
we're very close to Jeff Andrew who was
a Democrat and turned into a Republican
okay which is another point to be made
he ran as a moderate Democrat and then
switched because he saw the you know he
saw the signs he saw the crazy eyes
we're in an area that it's not as bad as
say Oh Kaiser Cortez district because I
think she's D plus 30 meaning like
that's huge know Philly Philly was 82%
Democrat voters in the 2016 election
like it's not gonna happen here however
if you're seeing Trump signs in this
neighborhood and I am I had a
conversation with a local guy last year
and it was kind of weird because he was
he was an anti-trump leftist it was
obvious but it was B was being polite
like he lived in the area and we were
talking we talked for quite some time
and then he starts saying things that
were very obviously left his talking
points a lot of it was fake news and I
was very polite and if you navigate
those things very carefully can't just
be like that's completely
what are you talking about you believe
that Lib [ __ ] blah blah yeah because you
will trigger their emotional defense
system right so I just said I I you know
I'm tactful and respectful and I said
well you know you saw the update on that
one right that that story about Trump
actually turned out to be this and then
he goes oh oh really and I was like oh
yeah and I just pulled my phone I'm like
yeah check it out he's like but he was
talking abunch of stuff about Hillary
and Trump being you know a Nazi and all
this stuff too and that was that I mean
dude were in a blue word with his blue
town men this is this is like 82% the
Philly area and this guy was talking
about this too for you to now walk
around the neighborhood and see Trump
signs and Trump stickers mm-hmm
I can't you know I saw that Trump flag
in the middle of the lake yes yeah it's
the termination guy easy and there's no
docks or anything right like how did
they do it they either wait it out there
or brought a boat and something maybe
you know I wouldn't even call it a lake
label I would call it like a scummy hot
water yeah it's it's it's an it's it's a
shopping center with just like a small
body of water full of trash and somebody
found a way to mount a Trump sign in the
middle of that thing so yeah I'm seeing
I'm seeing rhetoric from the Trump
supporters but I got to tell you man you
know what maybe it's just hubris but
there's a part of me that says when they
tore down a statue of Thomas Jefferson
mm-hmm that was a declaration of war
it feels like everything the average
American believes in you know it is
these internet drug addicts they've gone
insane you know they think they're the
majority but they're not they're like 1%
of the population
you know man I'd be willing to bet if
you go to any any house in Philly proper
any apartment yeah knock on the door
guy comes out what do thing about Thomas
Jefferson this is Philadelphia that's
true Thomas Jefferson yeah man
sorry dude yeah he's right what you
think about Ben Franklin yeah
good news George Washington dude we have
the Liberty Bell here man right this is
Philadelphia
the founding fathers times men wrote the
groundwork that opened up civil rights
to be had in the future weather was on
purpose or not you might have the
argument fine but I was watching this
video from from
Praeger you about Frederick Douglass
okay and one of his arguments was he's a
very very famous abolitionist born a
slave became free and he said something
about you know will the American people
have the will to live up to their own
constitution and and they were they were
pro-slavery people who are alive harumph
ah but he got him he's like I got you
you got to admit it it says right there
we're all equal are we or not yeah that
was that that was the beauty of what the
founding fathers wrote whether they
intended or not and I think they did
intend it I was reading about the
rebuttal to the 1619 project okay
historians actually writing about the
attitudes and I looked up a bunch of
other sources from before the whole
controversy and they all seem to back up
the general idea that although the
founding fathers were slave owners many
of them too tested it yeah and so for
like Thomas Jefferson he actually
inherited many of them and then he wrote
publicly he tried to get I believe he
did get it banned internationally he
stopped the importing of slaves and so
he was working to do what he could to
actually stop it did he do enough I'd
argue he could have done more I don't
know what it was like back in the 1700s
1800s yeah but that's that's always the
argument everyone always thinks that oh
well you could have done more
you're you're you're someone other than
me I don't want to do anything
right you can do more they didn't do
more I'm screeching it you know it's
like that's that's this whole thing that
we were screeching is become the norm
instead of accountability for your own
actions well I I just mean look Thomas
Jefferson did a lot of really really
great things yeah yeah it was a slave
owner and there were abolitionists at
the time and there were people who were
fighting for freedom and and yeah there
could have been more done and I bet a
lot of these people out there don't even
do the research to know who those people
are
oh for sure that's like tear down the
statues and and and then what they tore
down a statue of a guy who was a staunch
abolitionists yep or I think they deface
that I don't they tore it down I can
remember the guys name I was reading it
it was a bunch of conservatives posting
it they were saying that people didn't
know anything about the statue other
than he was a colonist and it was like
he would buy in free slaves and fought
really really hard to end it actively
and they'd to face it it's like you have
no idea you're talking about man no they
don't they they're trying to get a
statue of Abraham Lincoln torn down the
great Emancipator
for you want it you want to criticize
Lincoln it was the Republicans were 100%
anti-slavery yeah it was a new point in
time and they were like no yeah the
Democrats Democrats are the ones that
wanted to keep it around yeah you know
it's weird about the Dean and the
Democrats are the ones trying to get rid
of Thomas Jefferson and get rid of their
Civil Rights Act in California what's
that going on over there dude they want
to be its discriminate again the Calif
Democrats in California have officially
voted to repeal the civil rights
legislation it ran it through through
the assembly Wow now it goes to the
Senate and then and then I guess it'll
be I don't know if it'll be voted on or
ratified or however it works in
California but the the the Assembly
Democrats in California basically their
version of the house yeah have passed it
6214 but they'll on a discriminate
against insane the bill literally does
one thing what's that strikes through
the entire non-discrimination
legislation of prop 209 Wow so I send
this to my friends and they're
absolutely confused by it because the
Democrats know how dumb people are they
titled it the affirmative action
amendment Wow yup so I sent it to a
friend of mine who lives in California
and I said if this actually it's
ratified I will never set foot in
California again I was like cuz I do not
want to be made an example of based on
my race and and they said put
affirmative action have to understand
and I said well hell stop stop what
about affirmative action yeah did you
read the bill yeah I'm like okay well
the bill has nothing to do with
affirmative action right it literally
says the the the that it will you know
this this this bill or person provision
will remove section 31 chapter 1 of the
California Constitution and then it
shows you all the text that will be
removed and it literally says the state
shall not you know discriminate nor
provide for preferential treatment on
the basis of race color ethnicity sex
national origin semester they're
removing that that's and that that is a
mirror to the 1964 Civil Rights Act act
federally so I sent it to walk up I said
a bunch of my lefty friends like I want
you to explain this to me one of them
said affirmative action and when I tried
breaking it down like no
that's just the title of the bill did
you read what the bill does yeah it
makes it so that affirmative action is
in schools I said no no idea read what
the bill says and they were like I don't
understand you're saying it says
affirmative action I'm like that's the
title get past the title I'm not smart
open the book they can't open the book
read the book not the title of the book
right open the book read it so I don't
have another friend and we were talking
about political ideologies and I said
the problem with the political compass
is that me and everyone I know are left
libertarian the difference is I'm anti
identitarian and you coat you can't see
ideology on a political compass and so
my friend was like I said because of
this I reject most of the policies of
the progressives and the Democrats which
I don't make a conversation and I sent
them a link to the ballotpedia bill
saying they're revoking civil rights
legislation and they responded with you
know the thing about affirmative action
and I said Hollen let me stop you right
there you have to read past the title
Yeah right no offense and then guess
what they said next I don't need to know
no no no this one's better than that oh
great better than that it's good okay oh
geez what this is weird
okay yes yep so much better
a little glint of hope in humanity right
there they're good-natured people who
are being fed fake news yeah and don't
see this stuff and so I said can you
explain like what I'm supposed to do in
the face of this and it's like no no and
I was like yeah now you know why I'm
actively resisting these people yeah the
Republicans kicked out Steve King lost
his primary right yeah oh yeah it's like
dude hard again Steve King tweets about
white nationalism and they get rid of
the guy in two seconds
they even they're being accused and now
of licking the boots of black lives
matter because the Conservatives are not
far-right fringe extremists you know
they're like mostly moderate at this
points are still in the bell curve of
the average person they're actually
pretty close to the center and moving
left yeah it's yeah and and there's
there are scary problems with that and
that they won't stand up against the
people
down the edges of George Washington yeah
yeah dude I man I I would love you don't
want to do here's what I'm gonna do all
right nice smash to like man um you guys
should smash the like button also don't
forget we're doing the meme contest
later we hit mention that oh we haven't
but here's here's what I want to do I
would love to pay for any one of these
people to go to any one of these places
they claim is really really horrible
I'll pay for your trip there I actually
proposes is somebody a long time ago I
said you know we were we were arguing on
Facebook about all of these different
different you know political issues and
places and I said I'll tell you what
have you ever been to any one of these
places and they said no and I said how
would you like it if I paid how do you
like everything and and and and sent you
there let me know what you need if you
think you need security I will hire you
security if you think you want if you
want a camera to film it I will get
someone to film you and ultimately they
back out of course I had a I have a
friend in Chicago who's posting all this
crazy stuff about how racists you know
why people are in just the whole line
and I said all right bye bro I'll tell
you what man would you want to do a
project with me where we walk through
k-town it's on the south side of Chicago
it immediately stops talking we're
spawning on Facebook of course
immediately just stopped responding on
messenger you know what you know what
would happen if you walked through like
man I'm not gonna mention some of these
gangs but if one of these scrawny you
know little lefty progressive dudes that
I know from Chicago yeah that I've known
for a long time they know what happens
when you walk to that neighborhood let
me let me tell you a quick story I I
lived in this I lived on southside
eventually moved to the suburbs and I'm
skating in a suburb of Glen Ellyn it's
good fun suburbs way different from the
south side of Chicago man we were rough
and tumble it's night and day different
night and day Glen Ellyn take a tiny
little spot Glen Glen Ellyn is like
expensive houses suburb right by Wheaton
my cousin and uh and you're you're miles
away from the neck from like your
friend's house yeah that's like that's
like an hour outside of Chicago easy so
let me tell you about Southside okay I
mention this before a couple miles from
my house my buddy calls me one night and
says I'm watching someone drag a carpet
with feet sticking out of it in his
alley
literally I'm like yeah so not
far away in suburbs I'm talking my buddy
I got I got I got it was it was my
second car ever Dodge Neon and I'm like
let's go skate in the city we're gonna
go to I think the Wilson skate park so I
like driving down Roosevelt straight
from because it goes from Glen Ellyn it
goes straight into the city oh cool and
then Roosevelt's like 12 South so you do
go through the south side so we do this
and then I decided to turn left on some
stray camera but it was probably Halsted
or something maybe Harlem and the dudes
are hyperventilating really when he when
he realized where we were oh and I'm
laughing and he was like why are we here
dude what are you what are you doing oh
right we're driving we're fine
and I'm like the only thing you gotta
know is when you pull up to a car at a
red light you don't pull up net real
close do you leave a full car length
yeah because what they do is once you
get boxed in they run to your car and
and and mug you that's fine that's why
you always leave a full car length so if
you see someone walk to your car you
speed out and go for it I was like we're
gonna be fine bro but he was freaking
out so now this was somebody who was
from the suburbs who knew the reality of
the city of Chicago and the gun violence
chiraq and all that stuff and he was not
happy about me taking like I'm from the
city and dude and I'm you know and I
know people who are way more reckless
than I was but my ultra progressive
friends in the city I'd be like straight
up man I tell you what come with me to
the south side where I grew up we'll go
for a walk how does it sound gone huh
won't respond radio silence they know
yeah they've hurt you signal on Facebook
all this time but they ain't like they
like to say things like only white
people are racist it's like oh yeah why
do you want to take a trip with me to
like these certain neighborhoods man and
you want I'll give you a lesson on
racism yeah Chicago is a very very
horrifyingly racist sprite place its
segregated it's it's it's it's nasty
yeah so it's not it's it's not even
about it's it's this is bad
neighborhoods yeah honestly feels like
there's a an air of like a war on white
people right now it's like if you're
white it's like you're just wrong the
argument is they're pure existence is
offensive and racist it's been that way
for a long time
it's big it's been growing in comedy and
it and it starts with white people
recognizing the
at you know I think this was probably
you know following civil rights your
urine your in a dominant position you
know there's this there's I don't I
don't I don't think it's fair to call it
white privilege okay
I think it's majority privilege and
there's generational wealth and a bunch
of other factors that play a role in it
but you started getting self-deprecating
comedians who it's fine to make fun of
white people because you are white and
now it's evolved into everybody pile on
the white people all the time and
anything else is offensive and and now
it's getting twisted and weird where
Uncle Ben Uncle Ben rice it was
literally it's a it's an it's a picture
of a farmer yeah
from he was a farmer in 1946 that's the
image they they did they used he's got
to go mister clean the white dude shaved
head he's alright that's how weird it's
getting it is weird so it's all a bit
inverse that the the war on white people
narrative is kind of a weird narrative
it was popping up for a while I don't I
don't I don't you know I don't think
it's that I don't like framing it that
way I don't see it that way
what I see is racial identity Arianism
period and and solan break this down
okay it's not so much that it's a war on
white people
it's the racialization of everything and
the reason I think that but it's but
it's Asians you know what I mean it's
it's it's racial stereotyping of all
races yeah so naturally you get the
evolution of it's okay to make fun of
white people and now you're gonna get
white people feeling like they're being
attacked simply based on the color of
their skin yeah but then they they are
literally getting attacked like
physically attacked yeah yeah well you
got to be careful about this stuff to
the videos we see in is a lot of them of
white people just being attacked those
probably aren't new okay that's the end
and that's not I'm not saying it's
better yeah I'm saying you have to be
careful with this idea that it's it's a
new thing that white people are now
being attacked from you go to the south
side of Chicago I'll tell you I'll tell
you all about but it's not I've I've
been attacked you've been shot had I
that that was not a race thing though
right but I have other situations that
were completely I told you about my
uncle like I lost my uncle because he
was a white man and they thought that he
had money because he was white and he
got shot and killed yep and it's like
did that make me a racist no
but this is not at all that's but it
exists I see it I know it exists I'm not
gonna let it change me though the scary
thing about what the left is doing is
that it's creating white identitarian
ISM which was like going away yeah
after civil rights and you know the the
Loving v Virginia and then other
provision you know other amendments that
have been made over the past several
decades we were truly getting to a point
where race it was considered you know
taboo to use that as a pretext for
anything yeah and it became a secondary
it became an afterthought
you still had comedians who would bring
up race and make these points and people
recognize there was a lot way to do but
we were getting away from using race as
a pretext for anything you know the left
brought it back and when they started
normalizing the belittling and the
insulting of white people yeah it made a
lot of it created an incentive for many
young white people to form a racial
identity group and then you saw the rise
of the alt-right it's a good point so
the however the issue though is what
they're doing in California is it's not
about white people it's about them
controlling and segregating everybody
for whatever reason I don't know that
they want to keep us separated so we
don't we don't rise up and take over the
establishment that has kept us in
control for so long it's it's almost
glaringly obvious to me now so op they
don't they don't want us together they
don't want us to rise because we'll take
over
that's what we need to do we need to
take over well Trump is a populist and
that's why they hated him yeah Bernie
was the left populist but Bernie played
ball in two seconds yep immediately you
know Bernie Sanders said on the debate
stage and I love telling this to people
cuz they don't believe me if you're
white you don't know it's like to be
poor yeah that's where there was uh
there's a quote going around from a
French far left political leader and he
said the people who believe in white
privilege never met a poor white person
and I'm like that's like that's like a
far leftist in France what's up with
that why is America so twisted and
broken well you know I think we know if
we talked about the addiction it's that
it's the mental break it's it's funny to
me that it's so much more than just that
- there's so many things this cog
of this wheel's there's so many wheels
in this society that we have and they're
all getting all misshapen but they're
still turning but they're getting
morphed and lobbyists gross
it's decay it's decaying yes agreed
reminds me of like playing you know link
to the past or something oh god you're
like in a room in the floor starts
falling out and that is an amazing game
it's a great game great game but imagine
like the floors but you have to like run
and you're running and the floors
falling behind you feel like that's
what's happening yep like we're watching
the whole structure and system to start
falling apart and I think it's like a
zombification a rot a decay a breakdown
what you want to call it but the but I
do wanna I would I do want to stress the
point about what what what they are
doing with race and someone when I
pointed out to one of my friends that
there were appealed the civil rights
legislation they voted to repeal it in
in California and what that means I said
well I do think one of their preliminary
arguments is that they need to be able
to discriminate based on race in order
to create equality and you know so
that's what their argument is though
what they've argued specifically is
affirmative action they're trying to
they're trying to use affirmative action
as justification for repealing all civil
rights law in the public sphere
the argument is universities have too
many Asians so we need to be able to
stop Asians from getting in so stop stop
rewarding people on their merit and just
give it to them on their color of their
skin yeah and and lighten their workload
based on the color of their skin and
yeah that's racist of course it is the
assumption that a certain race couldn't
do it
yeah that's insane and they're 9 and
belittling yep I'd be pissed
yes I'm white yeah but I mean I didn't
go to college I got lucky and knew
someone amazing like Tim Poole called me
up and said hey you want to do a show
with me and I this is where I am you
know it's like but basing anything like
that on the color of your skin is just
it it blows my mind away it's like the
fact that people are okay with it a
minority is a it's more like hey you
know what
you're you're less than us now so you
don't have to do as much it's like how
belittling is that and hey be pissed
they don't just think it's okay they are
actively trying to make it happen
I think it's good but this is the main
point it's it's about all of the races
and I don't think it's an attack on any
one race
I think it's literally them being like
we want to make sure you're all
digitized tonight little nice little
packages where we can separate you and
control which group goes where mm-hmm so
when they say we can't have it's for who
the craziest thing about Asians when
they say there's too many Asians in the
university a lot of my progressive
friends go well it is true there's like
a disproportion amount of Asians and I
said what does that mean what Asian yeah
Indian Chinese Laotian Vietnamese Korean
Japanese Filipino come on come on
Malaysian they have no idea what that
means they don't they don't have any
clue so you're telling me that you've
taken half the planet put it onto one
continent and then said this entire
ethnic region that the western eastern
hemisphere is now one group
it's insane Wow yeah so I have to wonder
what their real motivations are when
they when they try and argue that a poor
Vietnamese immigrant is the same as a
wealthy Indian and wealthy Indian
immigrant right or a poor Vietnamese you
know kid born in America second
generation growing up in the ghetto they
say well you know no matter how hard he
works we're not gonna go to Harvard
they're just like they try to create a
caste system and they found therein
mm-hmm seems like a thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you